e
e e
time being uh 1030 I would like to open
up the uh executive session on uh Senate
Bill
543 and before we do I would like to
thank uh representative
brenen Bren thank you and our second
Newman thank
you thank you both for being here
today um
so establishing a state environmental
adaptation res uh resilience and
Innovation
Council uh do we have a motion for
Senate Bill
543 uh thank you Mr chair I I move auto
pass for SB
543 um Edgar um moves off to pass um and
I will second that uh discussion on this
bill
seeing
none is there a discussion seeing
none um the uh clerk will call the role
if you're in favor of Senate Bill 543
you'll uh respond in the affirmative uh
I if you or yes and if you are opposed
nay or no with that the clerk please
thank you Mr chair representative cluder
yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative
fidi votes
no representative
Newton is not
president
oh okay representative
kazinski representative Bowden is
out representative Boyd is not here
representative Melvin no
representative
bogert
yes representative
Connor
yes representative Jack
yes representative Abbott
yes representative Edgar
I representative Faulkner
yes representative soon
Newman
yes representative Brennan
yes representative Peterson yes
representative vone yes representative
Ray
Newman
yes chairman
mononi
I Mr chair the motion passes
143 thank you uh is there any objection
to
consent seeing none we will put it on
the
consent that's the only business per
that's our business St all right we have
uh we were notified that we have four
bills for
um interm study is that what it was and
we will we will pull that together a
little later um and we will distribute
that list to all of you um we've
concluded our business here for today I
appreciate you taking the time out of
your day to be here rep including yeah a
question about bills that are now before
the Senate do you know of any Senate
amendments and or committees plan
Committees of conference that you want
to we I I have not been notified at this
point in time I I'm expecting we will
have at least one on a rather major bill
of our own okay right okay okay great
thank you all right any other
questions thank you so much
okay
e
e for